my brother actually got me into you this
past Year's been a tough year for me our
mom's been battling cancer and I really
just wanted to
to use this Outlet to kind of thank my
brother because he's been the most
amazing person through the whole
situation and and I've been at college
so I don't have a whole lot of money so
he's been he takes me out every weekend
he shows me a good time and he's helped
me through a really rough breakup and
he's just the most amazing guy he flew
us out to Denver uh to go visit our
cousin and um I just wanted to spread a
little bit of positivity because you
know he's a huge listener and he got me
into you that's cool bro
that's cool that you got you know your
brother you guys are out there you guys
are on the front lines for the family
you know you got cancer on the you know
on the horizon but you guys got it in
your scopes with your hearts and you
guys are caring about each other dude
and just trying you know
man it's crazy how much my brother is it
makes me think of my own brother
and I'm sure there's a lot of people who
live you know whoever's listening to
this this right now that uh
are thinking about their brother man
dude my brother used to make me listen
to all of his music that's the only
thing I knew about music it still only
the type of music I really even know
people ask me about music
I'm like uh I don't I listen to maybe
Rodney James Dio Tesla
you know I listen to some NWA I listen
to them
I listen to whatever my brother listened
to
you know it's funny when you're young
and stuff you just want to be your
brother so bad even if he beats you like
damn my brother beat my ass but damn bro
he's awesome you know
you just want to be your brother so bad
it's so interesting how that happens at
that age I'm glad you got a teammate in
the world and there's a lot of kids that
are just their only children so they
don't really get that opportunity it's
like we all have this different gift man
we all have some people got a gift some
of it's on the inside some of it's on
the outside some of us have a brother
some of us don't some of us have a
sister
some of us have two children some of us
can't have children
some of us can juggle some of us can't
read
dude the guy that can't read oh yeah
sucks a lot of the times but when he
walks back by a bookstore and
feels no uh regret
Gold Mine of comfort
there's all the every there are two
sides to the sword
you know there's two sides to every
sword bro you care about your brother
and that makes me feel good because it
makes me think about my brother dude
remember there's such a weird guy bro
and he's so hard on himself dude but
he's such a loving guy and uh and he
tries his best and
you know and we just he and I were hard
on ourselves because we don't you know
we developed our own sense of what was
okay or what wasn't and we didn't you
know nobody was home nobody was hard on
us or easy on us and so we didn't know
and and our brains don't want to leave
you know sometimes if you develop your
own thing in your head that thing can
sometimes be mean
you know and but I know man my brother's
like my you know he's my idol now and
he's not perfect I need and I'm and I'm
far from that and and we never will be
but
you know we have these little moments
sometimes where
you know he's just everything I always
wanted him to be and I'm never probably
fully be able to let him know that but
but that's some of my journey you know I
get to be a brother in this lifetime
man that's cool
you know I get to call somebody who has
the same blood I have in my body and
their body and let them know hey man
you know how's that flow going bro we're
riding on a on a risky River aren't we
with this blood is category 4 Rapids
right now ain't it brother we boiling
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one